en el escenario de los disturbios del 6
de enero de 2021 las fuerzas de
seguridad no se arriesgan A última hora
del lunes se instalaron barreras
metálicas alrededor del Capitolio de
Estados Unidos en medio de la
preocupación por las protestas a favor
de Trump el expresidente dijo que creía
que sería arrestado como parte de una
investigación criminal sobre el dinero
pagado a una actriz de cine adulto como
parte de un presunto soborno en las
horas previas a la vista judicial un
pequeño grupo de sus partidarios se
concentró frente a la torre Trump en
Nueva York lo irónico Es que creo que
solo le ayuda creo que solo le convierte
en un mártir y creo que mucha gente en
el lado demócrata que lo ve de la misma
manera en cuanto salgan las próximas
encuestas probablemente se disparará en
las primarias y creo que sus números en
los sondeos probablemente subirán en
general la investigación de Manhattan se
centra en 130 mil dólares que se pagaron
a la actriz stormy Daniels semanas antes
de las elecciones presidenciales de 2016
todo para evitar que se hiciera pública
una relación que dice haber tenido con
El Magnate años antes el ex abogado de
Trump Michael cohen dice que hizo el
pago y que fue reembolsado por Trump
Aunque el expresidente dijo inicialmente
que la suma era un anticipo mensual se
cree que los fiscales están considerando
cargos de falsificación de registros
comerciales y las recientes llamadas a
declarar de Testigos han indicado que el
gran Jurado podría estar concluyendo su
investigación aunque no se ha anunciado
ninguna decisión
varias figuras republicanas como el ex
vicepresidente Mike pence dicen que la
investigación tiene motivaciones
políticas
si se formula una acusación Trump se
convertiría en el primer expresidente o
presidente en ejercicio acusado de un
delito